india and south africa have led calls
for vaccine patterns to be waived
in theory allowing more countries to
make more
cheaper doses and now the united states
has joined them
it's a hugely significant diplomatic
move but one that's left the
pharmaceutical industry
for whom patents equal profits that fund
research
unhappy having the pharmaceutical
industry as a partner not a punch bag
is the best way to make this this
production happen
as fast as possible as it has in the uk
in the last year
the oxford vaccine was developed here by
academic scientists backed with public
funds
produced by pharmaceutical giant
astrazeneca and sold at
cost those behind it say simply handing
over the patent
will not solve supply problems i'm not
really aware of any facilities around
the world that are suitably equipped to
make it
that aren't doing so already so
i think it in the short term the next
few months
the amount of faxing that's going to be
available is fixed
the question is how it gets distributed
the industry says that collaborations
like this bringing together academic
know-how
with public money and the scale provided
by big pharma
has been fundamental to the success of
the vaccine program
and the real question the developed
nations should be considering is not
whether to give away the patterns
but whether to give away the doses they
already have
in african nations covid19 has echoes of
the aids epidemic
when patents prevented affordable
versions of life-saving drugs
reaching millions of people covid
vaccines are more complex and harder to
reproduce
but the memory looms large that
generation
that lost loved ones to the delayed
response to
actually ensuring equitable access to
necessary commodities save lives that
generation is alive today
and those memories are alive today the
british government has not
followed america's lead but says it will
work with the world
trade organization to increase supplies
but that could take
months until then the world's poor
will rely on the rich to share the doses
they need
paul kelso sky news in oxford